[Musique]
bonsoir à tout ça y'est dernier journal
de la saison sur tb 60,18 bienvenue dans
cette édition tout de suite les titres
de ce jeudi 11 juillet le défilé du 14
juillet se prépare dans les yvelines ce
matin les troupes à pied ont répété
l'événement au camp militaire de satory
à versailles près de 4300 femmes et
hommes participeront à la traditionnelle
parade ce dimanche sur les champs
elysées à montigny le bretonneux le
bureau de poste avenue du centre des
ménages depuis le début de la semaine il
a pris ses nouveaux quartiers au sein de
l'espace saint quentin le centre
commercial signé mon teint l ancien site
sera 8 démoli et puis à la fin de ce
journal nous vous emmenons sur les
routes des yvelines un été à la
découverte des châteaux du territoire le
département en compte une bonne centaine
de toutes époques et découverte de trois
d'entre eux
tout à l'heure nous parlerons également
des aidants le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer un congé indemniser les
concernant présentation également du bal
des pompiers qui revient une nouvelle
fois cette année à versailles avant de
développer ses titres neuf jeunes âgés
de 17 à 25 ans mise en examen ils font
partie des 17 personnes arrêtées lors du
gros coup de filet réalisé par les
forces de l'ordre ce mardi dans les
yvelines
ces individus sont accusés de violences
volontaires et participation à un
groupement armée en vue de violence sur
personne ils sont placés en contrôle
judiciaire pour rappel le 29 juin
dernier une violente rixe entre bandes
rivales avaient éclaté dans le quartier
du bel air à saint germain en laye trois
individus avaient été à gravement blessé
lors de cette bagarre
un déménagement de quelques mètres le
bureau de poste de l'avenue du centre de
montigny le bretonneux a déménagé
investi ses nouveaux locaux en début de
semaine installé au sein de l'espace
saint quentin le site fait plus de 500
mètres carrés et comprend services
postaux banques et patrimoine mélanie
poquet pour le reportage sur place et
des automates accessible en dehors des
horaires d'ouverture et une vingtaine de
salariés pour accueillir la clientèle
depuis le 9 juillet dernier le bureau de
poste de saint quentin en yvelines a
investi ses nouveaux locaux ça fait
quelques temps qu'on cherchait des
locaux
pour moderniser l'ancien bureau or on
est sur une surface de 510 mètres carrés
donc c'est assez dur à trouver
et on a eu l'opportunité avec les deux
boutiques étaient ici de récupérer les
locaux et donc de venir s'implanter au
plus près sans s'éloigner néanmoins de
la gare le site propose les mêmes
services que le précédent bureau qui
accueillait 1000 clients par jour et les
nouveaux locaux sont au sein même de
l'espace saint quentin c'est beaucoup
plus éclairés c'est plus pratique pour
nous en plus si on veut faire quelques
commissions à côté c'est très pratique
il était déjà pas très loin de chez moi
quand ils étaient près de la gare donc
ça change pas grand chose pour moi mais
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
moderne et puis celui du centre
commercial donc ça très bien devant les
anciens locaux situés à deux pas de la
gare la boîte aux lettres a laissé place
aux palissades de chantier
le bâtiment est voué à la destruction le
futur édifice sera occupé par
l'opérateur orange
une mesure controversée qui fait qui a
fait beaucoup parler il ya moins d'un an
la limitation de vitesse sur les axes
secondaires à double sens en séparateur
central est passé de 90 à 80 km/heure
emmerdes en mai dernier
cependant le premier ministre edouard
philippe a finalement annoncé que les
départements seraient libres de choisir
les axes au cas par cas où les 90 km
heure pourrait être remise en vigueur un
peu plus de 50 collectivités vont
revenir à cette vitesse dont les
yvelines le territoire prévoit de passer
aux 90 km/heure sur environ à 500 dès
1600 km de routes départementales 85
panneaux seront à rechange et quelle
stratégie pour la santé publique et
l'offre de soins quelle réponse apporter
face aux déserts médicaux quelques unes
des questions qui seront soulevées à
demain lors d'une grande convention de
la droite et du centre à versailles
organisé par le président du sénat
gérard larcher et celui du conseil
départemental pierre bédier elle se
déroulera à l'université interâges
l'objectif de ces conventions
reconstruire après l'échec des
républicains aux dernières élections
préparer les municipales en 2020 puis
les départementales et régionales en
ces tables rondes auront lieu jusqu'en
octobre date de la grande convention
nationale où sera présenté le projet de
la droite et du centre
'l'annonce est en date du 3 juillet
dernier
le gouvernement prépare actuellement un
plan pour les aidants alors les détails
seront connus à la rentrée même à
l'automne les mesures attendues parmi
les mesures attendues est la création
d'un congé rémunéré pour ces personnes
qui s'occupent d'un proche dépendant
comment réagissent les professionnels de
santé au contact de ces aidants va poser
la question tout de suite à nos deux
invités nathalie bouaziz bonsoir ça vous
est la responsable du centre d'accueil
de jour et de la plateforme
d'accompagnement des aidants de
l'hôpital de la porte verte c'est à
versailles et nous avons également le
docteur adèle de malherbe bonsoir vous
êtes vous la responsable du pôle
médico-social de l'hôpital de la porte
verte un petit point définition déjà les
dents est une personne qui accompagnent
un proche dépendant à partir de quel
moment et ont considéré comme est donc à
la fois de malheur peut-être qu'on est
considéré comme aidant de manière assez
naturelle finalement puisque la relation
dead fait partie de l'humanité on peut
citer comme exemple la relation qu une
mère peut avoir avec son enfant mais la
loi de l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement a défini
alors qu'elle est entrée en vigueur en
2016 ce qui est un proche et dont est en
fait un proche aidant c'est une personne
qui à titre non professionnel aide
quelqu'un de son entourage dans les
actes de la vie quotidienne
alors elles aident régulièrement et sur
le long terme et c'est ça qui fait que
cette personne peut être considérée
comme un proche aidant il y a environ 8
millions de proches aidants sur le
territoire en france elles ont toutes
âgées peut s'agir d'enfants d'adultes de
personnes qui qui sont en situation de
retraite
en tout cas il y à la moitié d'actifs
dans cette population de proches aidants
non vous qui côtoyez justement ces
aidants au quotidien ce qu'il souffre
d'un manque de reconnaissance de leur
statut
d'une certaine manière oui alors il y a
toujours eu des aidants comme je le sais
c'est quelque chose d'assez assez
naturelle mais le vieillissement de la
population le traitement des maladies
qui a progressé 1 avec les progrès de la
science fait que le nombre de ces
aidants en fait augmenté il s'agit donc
pour la société de reconnaître peut-être
une vulnérabilité particulière et de
prendre les mesures qui sont associés à
cette vulnérabilité
alors dans les mesures en 2020 en tout
cas le gouvernement va créer un congé à
indemniser pour les aidants la ministre
de la santé agnès buzyn a assuré que
cette mesure figurerait au prochain
budget de la sécurité sociale
un plan pour les aidants est également
en préparation un plan plus global
comment vous voulez accueilli ces
annonces alors bien sûr d'être d'accord
on les accueille très bien il s'agit
déjà d'un projet d'indemnisation du
congé qui existe qui a été proposé par
la loi d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement mais qui malheureusement
n'est pas ou peu utilisés par les
prochainement puisque la plupart ne
peuvent pas en fait se permettre
financièrement de cesser leurs activités
parce que vous répondre on rappelle
comment sont établis les choses les
aidants droit à trois mois maximum de
congés c'est un congé qui n'est pas
indemnisée aujourd'hui oui ces trois
mois qui est renouvelable d'une durée
maximum de 1 an et ce n'est pas
indemnisée actuellement donc le projet à
d'indemnisation et puis aussi
le la possibilité d'avoir un droit
contributifs à la retraite pendant cette
période là est effectivement très
intéressant
je dirais que les interrogations qu'on
garde nous professionnels c'est de se
dire qu'elle va être exactement public
concerné est ce que ça va être seulement
le public des personnes âgées qui ont
besoin d'être pour le quotidien ou
est-ce que ça va être aussi le public
des personnes handicapées quel va être
le niveau de rémunération est ce que ce
sera à la hauteur des besoins des
personnes
et quelle va être la durée puisqu'on
disait trois mois renouvelable jusqu'à
durée d'un an actuellement est ce que ça
ça va changer pour la future loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
ce sont des questions qui pour lesquels
on n'a pas encore de réponse nous on
devrait peut-être avoir plus de réponse
à l'automne puisque plus de détails
seront dévoilés par le gouvernement en
octobre alors justement à l'hôpital delà
de la porte verte à versailles les
aidants peuvent bénéficier d'un
accompagnement il ya une plateforme
dédiée dont vous êtes la responsable
nathalie bouaziz déjà depuis combien de
temps existe-t-elle
et quels sont les objectifs de cette
plateforme
alors cette plateforme existe depuis
cinq ans maintenant elle a ouvert en
donc nous nous accueillons
du public nos missions ça va être de
répondre aux besoins d'information de
formation de soutien d' écoute des
personnes qui accompagnent au quotidien
un proche en situation de dépendance ça
va être aussi de permettre un repérage
des besoins des couples aidants aidés
comme le soulignait le docteur de
malades tout à l'heure ce qui est
important que si c'est vraiment la
relation dead est de préserver une bonne
qualité de la relation au sein des
couples et dont aider pour nous aussi il
va être important de mettre en place des
actions de répit avec notamment la mise
en place d'un forfait temps libre à
domicile pour libérer les temps est lui
prêt à permettre d'avoir un relais y âge
et puis permettre aux aidants et au
couple aidant aidé de préserver une vie
sociale qui nous semble primordial
donc j'ai pas d'émissions notamment
quelques actions déployées et comment ça
fonctionne concrètement cette plateforme
alors la plateforme est ouverte du lundi
au vendredi elle est située sur le site
de l'hôpital de la porte verte elle est
adossée à un centre d'accueil de jour
qui accueille des personnes atteintes de
maladies neuro évolutive et sont
présents chaque jour sur cette
plateforme trois professionnels qu'ils
font à la fois de l'accueil physique et
téléphonique et organise des actions en
faveur des aidants le croit
professionnels qui composent l'équipe
pause l'équipe
voilà alors ces trois professionnels
sont là à mi temps une secrétaire prend
l'ensemble des appels et ensuite les
demandes sont traitées par la
psychomotricienne qui est présente sur
un mi-temps et moi même alors vous
disiez cette plateforme est localisée à
versailles quelle zone d'action zone de
couverture at elle alors la plateforme
elle a vraiment une action de proximité
elle l accueil des personnes qui
habitent versailles et les communes
alentours ce qu'on appelle le grand
versailles
donc ces quatorze communes qui sont
autour de versailles pour en citer
quelques unes bucs châteaufort
toussus-le-noble concours le che mais
les clayes-sous-bois vélizy villacoublay
et il ya un certain mais on peut avoir
toutes les informations sur son site
internet
exactement sur le site de l'hôpital ou
en nous appelant tout simplement si
cette affiche et plusieurs fonds
associés d'hôpital et qui s'affiche à
nouveau merci à vous deux docteurs adèle
de malherbe responsable du pôle
médico-social de l'hôpital de la porte
verte et merci à vous nathalie bouaziz
je rappelle que vous êtes la responsable
du centre d'accueil de jour dont vous
parliez et de cette plateforme est bien
sûr d'accompagnement des aidants delà de
l'hôpital de la porte verte c'est à
versailles
nj - 3 avant le traditionnel défilé du
14 juillet sur les champs-elysées une
manifestation qui nécessite bien sûr
plusieurs jours de travail les à troupes
à pied à s'entraîne depuis mardi sur le
site militaire de satory dans les
yvelines la cession de ce matin était
suivi par aurélie ronces 14 formation
d'école militaire ouvriront le défilé
des troupes à pied cette année pour la
majeure partie des effectifs ce 14
juillet 2019 sera donc une première
c'est une bonne surprise déjà est un
grand honneur parce que
j'étais loin d'imaginer il ya quelques
moins de faire le 14 juillet et surtout
en école ce n'est pas un hasard si les
troupes à pied répète sur le site
militaire de satory
ils présentent quasiment les mêmes
caractéristiques techniques que les
champs elysées une piste rectiligne qui
reproduit la ligne d'éclatement devant
les tribunes
[Musique]
avec 116 pas par minute la concentration
le sérieux sont de rigueur chaque troupe
est minutieusement observés durant les
entraînements
le bandeau vous pour vos difficultés
c'est qu'ici on veut la perfection le
haut niveau de tous qui alignement au
niveau de tout ce qui est cadencement
balancier essaie de tendre sur cette
perfection c'est vrai que c'est un peu
plus contraignant que ce qu'on fait en
régime mais ces deux largement
atteignable et le but c'est d'être
parfait pour que le défilé qui sera
réalisée soigner soit impeccable 4299
femmes et hommes descendront la plus
belle avenue du monde cette année
parmi eux les yvelinois revenir à satory
hier des entraînements
un quotidien pour être au niveau on
arrivera à satory et 6 à 7 aurions fait
des dernières corrections
avec des répétitions relativement ce
n'est fier parce que
c'est que la famille va regarder
j'espère que ça va bien se passer mais
en est fier c'est un honneur d'être des
tripiers pour le défilé du 14 juillet
cette année le défilé du 14 juillet est
placée sous le signe de la coopération
européenne l'allemagne ou encore
l'espagne seront représentés le 14
juillet moment festif dans tout le pays
avec c'est une tradition le bal des
pompiers plusieurs sont organisées dans
les yvelines
et dès le samedi 13 juillet à la caserne
de poids si elle vous convie pour son
événement annuel à partir de 19h30 et
deuxième édition du bal des pompiers à
rambouillet le rendez vous est donné à
19 heures une tombola sera proposée avec
à la clé une semaine à new york à
remporter enfin montigny le bretonneux a
choisi le jour de la fête nationale pour
le troisième balle de la caserne les
pompiers vous attendre dimanche à partir
de 19h30 et à versailles aussi les
pompiers remettent ça jusqu'à l'année
dernière il n'y avait pas eu de balles
dans la cité royale
en 40 ans mais ça c'est du passé après
une édition à 2018 réussi un nouveau bal
est organisé ce samedi
rendez-vous à la caserne de versailles à
20h et c'est jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
pour en parler
le commandant philippe casarin bonsoir
monsieur vous êtes le chef du centre de
secours principal de versailles
également l'adjudant olivier morello
bonsoir en ce moment président de
l'amicale des sapeurs-pompiers de
versailles vous êtes derrière
l'organisation de ce bal des pompiers
3700 personnes l'année dernière c'était
une évidence de remettre ça cette année
face à face aux résultats de la soirée
effectivement c'était l'été à impossible
de passer à côté de ce rendez vous
populaire une grosse ferveur des gens
qui sont venus nous voir et une demande
de la mairie de versailles qui est
co-organisatrice de l'événement de
renouveler face au succès de la première
édition
est-ce que c'est plus facile après une
première édition réussie d'attirer les
sponsors d'organiser finalement plus
facilement ce bal des pompiers
oui c'est effectivement face aux
résultats du premier bal
c'est un petit peu plus facile les gens
en fait nous ont donné rendez-vous à des
là dès la fin de la première édition
pour
nous voulons commencer cette année et si
on vient juste oui vous vouliez ajouter
quelque chose commandant en effet nous
bénéficions toute l'année virer d'un
taux de l'adhésion de la population et
c'était l'occasion l'occasion à traire
ce bal également de d'ouvrir nos portes
à la population pour leur manifester
entre notre bienveillance et mettre
notre total soutien à l'occasion d'une
soirée festive et républicaine et c'est
une symbolique finances parce que
d'habitude c'est les pompiers qui se
rendent chez les personnes pour diverses
opérations là les pompiers accueille au
sein de la caserne
nous avons en effet différents
événements qui nous permettent d'ouvrir
nos portes à la population nous
organiser nous organisons pardon
ponctuellement des opérations portes
ouvertes nous présentant les facettes de
notre métier est depuis quelques années
en effet les sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines organise sur différents sites
et des bals populaires
c'est vraiment sur ce sujet de faire
venir la population au sein de sein de
l'unité de partager un moment de
convivialité festif autour je dirais une
programmation amicale et musicale est en
effet des retours de la première édition
était très positif avec un angle aussi
caritatif puisque l'année dernière vous
avez soutenu l'oeuvre des pupilles des
sapeurs pompiers avec 2000 euros
récoltés pour pour cette association ça
c'est aussi important cet angle
caritatif et c2c le deuxième axe
principal de cette soirée bien sûr ces
deux répondre à une demande de la
population de pouvoir faire la fête mais
pour nous il est important que les
bénéfices qui sont dégagés de cette
soirée seront reversés à l'oeuvre des
pupilles notre soutien social pour la
pour le tout les sapeurs-pompiers twins
ont parlé de sept cases et un petit
s'ouvre à la population comment on
transforme justement une caserne en un
lieu fait pour une pleine forêt un lieu
de fête certes mais au sein duquel
perdure l'activité opérationnelle il
s'agit même appartient ce que dans cette
forêt les pompiers seront sollicités
continuer à partir en intervention
la casa de versailles s'est dit mes
interventions par an c'est 30 départs
par jour en moyenne
donc évidemment à l'occasion du bal il y
aura les départs en intervention et qui
seront évidemment assuré sans difficulté
et parallèlement la population pourra
venir
la fête au sein de sein des casernes et
du coup quelques ajustements peut-être
de la caserne pour l'adapter à ce lieu
d'égaliser à cet événement et ça fait 48
heures qu'on travaille sur la
transformation justement de la caserne
pour la rendre plus accueillante et
festive possible avec un objectif fixé
cette année accueillir 5000 personnes
comment comptez-vous y parvenir
peut-être la communication davantage de
communication
on n'a pas d'objectif chiffré pour nous
l'objectif principal c'est encore une
fois d'accueillir la population qui
souhaitent s'associer à nous à
l'occasion de la fête nationale
l'objectif étant vraiment encore une
fois de passer tous ensemble un moment
festif et sympathique et on on y
travaille on travaille à travers une
opération de communication important
partenaire avec la mairie de versailles
qui est un partenaire qui me suit depuis
deux ans donc les pompiers tract de
l'affichage est en cours et également
sur les médias sociaux et sur les médias
tout cours d'une partie avec une petite
vidéo teasing qu'on a pu voir satisfait
pendant l'entretien divers moyens de
communication le programme de la soirée
le retour de dj nicky stevenson
tout à fait après sa participation pour
la première édition autres artistes
vedettes qui est en train de percer
comme on l'avait dit l'année dernière
qui est passé sur des chaînes de radios
nationales et sur des grands festival
techno en france et en europe
voilà une fait l'honneur de revenir
cette année sur nadal et le reste du
programme du coût et durée du programme
la fanfare saranga le scopitone guerre
pendant et en première partie de dj au
legs qui aura un accompagnant logicap
plus + musique plus familial et plus on
dirait des années 80 avec peut-être la
mission de chauffer un peu la salle
exactement cette soirée comme on y
participe à ce bas il ya des préventes
qui sont d'ores et déjà disponibles
toujours des pré ventes en ligne
vous passez par la page facebook des
pompiers de versailles il s'affiche avec
avec le lien réservé en direct ou sinon
sur place directement à l'entrée du bal
donc la prévente 8 euros avec une
boisson offerte est un cadeau un et le
soir de l'événement 10 euros l'entrée
avec une boisson en faire 10 euros sur
place c'est gratuit c'est gratuit pour
les moins de 16 ans et gratuit pour les
moins de 16 ans accompagnés d'un adulte
bien sûr mais bon balle à vous merci de
votre présence est d'être venu présenter
ce bal commandant casarin merci aussi à
l'adjudant morello le bal des pompiers
de versailles ce samedi à partir de 20
heures et c'était c'est bien sûr au
centre de secours principal de
versailles on peut célébrer le 14
juillet aussi en famille devant un feu
d'artifice plusieurs sont proposés dans
le département ce programme qui est loin
d'être exhaustif et des communes ont
décidé de mutualiser l'événement c'est
le cas de plaisir et des
clayes-sous-bois qui donnent rendez vous
samedi dans le parc du château de
plaisir et dès 21h montigné voisins le
bretonneux ont elles choisi à leur site
commun du bassin de la sourderie pour le
spectacle pyrotechnique 7 à 23 heures ce
sera la coulée verte
à la même heure et pour le même jour à
maurepas et l'encours du en cours et rap
organise également un chacun est de leur
côté leur feu d'artifice enfin
rambouillet fera le sien le dimanche 14
juillet sept à 22h45 dans le parc du
château
allez pour refermer ce dernier journal
de la saison je vous propose maintenant
d'aller à la rencontre de trésorerie
vinoy mika et demi d'euros est parti en
road trip sur la route et des châteaux
du département visite guidée des château
de monte-cristo celui de ben et du
donjon de houdan
[Musique]
je vous propose de vous emmener sur la
route des châteaux des yvelines et y en
a une vingtaine dans le département et
nous en avons sélectionné trois à ces
partis
première escale le château de
monte-cristo port-marly cet ancien
vignoble a été transformée par
l'écrivain alexandre dumas à la moitié
du 19e siècle
présentation de ce style néo renaissance
[Musique]
à mots pour caractériser ce château une
porte tout l'âme d'alexandre dumas
je crois que c'est ça qui caractérise
monte cristo essentiellement et qu'est
ce qui fait sa spécificité sur le
château est sculpté de toutes parts vous
pourrez voir des visages d'écrivains des
sculptures divers des instruments de
musique des armes d
des personnages mi ange mi végétaux des
bouquets de fleurs des bouquets de
fruits face et c'est très étonnant
il faut lire la façade du château
aujourd'hui il fait très beau on peut se
promener dans les jardins c'est aussi ça
qui fait la beauté du lieu
oui bien sûr le château est inscrit dans
un parc romantique aménager l anglaise
avec des grottes des rocailles des
cascades c'est vraiment un vrai bonheur
de se promener là et vous organiser des
événements également pendant cet été
cet été nous avons une exposition d'art
contemporain qui est installée au
deuxième étage du château il faut venir
voir des oeuvres très étonnante d'un
artiste américain qui s'appelle à doute
jamal merci beaucoup frédéric l'hérault
visiter tout ça
m
quand on
deuxième étape de notre périple après le
style néo renaissance place au style
médiéval
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit des ruines mais ce qui est
vraiment horrible alors effectivement
lorsqu'on s'approche de ce château on a
vraiment l'impression d'un tas de ruine
envahie par la végétation
il faut quand même que vous sachiez que
ce château déjà un peu plus de mille ans
d'histoire il fut forteresse médiévale
il a été ensuite résidence royale est
aujourd'hui effectivement il nous donne
cette image un petit peu délabré bien
sûr il y à toute l'histoire qui est
passé par séverine mais il est toujours
vivant il est toujours debout et son
histoire est particulièrement
intéressante il un avantage également
c'est qu'il est gratuit si on veut venir
pour visiter autour on peut le boire
tout à fait nous sommes l'association
qui nous occupons particulièrement du
château nous assurons des visites pour
des groupes constitués au bouquet
rendez-vous mais surtout pour les
journées du patrimoine le dimanche des
journées du patrimoine il sera ouvert à
tous le public de 10h à 18h le soir
gratuitement
et là nous faisons des visites racontant
l'histoire de ce grand château
troisième étape de notre périple le
donjon de houdan qui datent du 12e
siècle on va le visiter
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut visiter ici
dans le donjon de houdan alors on peut
visiter une exposition toute l'année sur
le donjon deux dents sur son histoire
sur ces différentes occupations et une
utilisation au cours des siècles mais on
peut aussi visiter des expositions
temporaires en ce moment une exposition
sur les chouettes jusqu'à la fin août
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir le
patrimoine des yvelines oui le donjon de
houdan c'est un monument historique de
la fin du xiième siècle
il a été rénové récemment et il est
ouvert au public depuis trois ans
maintenant et combien ça coûte ça coûte
4 euros pour les adultes 2 euros pour
les enfants jusqu'à 6 ans et c'est
gratuit pour les enfants de moins de 6
ans
avec ces trois visites j'espère que je
vous ai donné envie de découvrir le
patrimoine yvelinois si vous avez encore
des questions rendez vous sur le site
internet divine tourisme moi je vais
continuer encore un petit peu les
visites
[Musique]
peu de temps cet été entre deux parties
de boules de pétanque ce rendez vous à
ne pas manquer pendant les vacances sur
tv 78 nous avons est délocalisée notre
plateau à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines pour une émission
spécialité sur du 7-8 loisirs autour de
wilfrid riche et de ses invités toute la
rédaction vous donne et des idées de
sorties et d'activités à faire dans le
département pendant la période estivale
7,8 loisirs spéciale à retrouver le
lundi 22 juillet à 20 heures où pendant
tout l'été sur tv 78 émission à voir
également en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
voilà c'est la fin de ce dernier journal
de la saison sur tb 78 j'ai été très
heureux de vous présenter ses 167
édition tout au long de l'année merci à
la rédaction
merci également aux équipes techniques
derrière la caméra sont acquis à rien ne
serait possible à l'info locale revient
le lundi de septembre c'est à 18h en
direct sur tv 60 18 d'ici là portez vous
bien et très bel été à tous
[Musique]